I'm sure at some point at Jimmy Fallon's
prom they were rocking a little new
addition their rise to fame and the
bumps in the road did they hit are the
subject of a new B et miniseries why hit
the set where the original band is
keeping a close eye on the young talents
we're playing them way back in the day
what goes through your head when you
look through that and remember those
moment those outcomes and those hairdos
it's like running through my hair JAMA
the miniseries features a cast of up and
comers including Empires Brashear gray
how does it feel wearing you know some
good fabric but it takes us back to the
new edition days when it was on tour
will you guys do a concert or
performance promote this if the fans
want it I promise you we probably could
put some together clearly they must be
doing something right the scenes that
they were shooting when I visited were
almost exactly like a concert we shot
back in 1986
et has been with new addition all
through their breakups and reunions
including their 2014 collaboration that
have Bobby Brown back with the boys
you're getting back together with the
guys going out on the road what's it
like now it's fun it's just isn't you
know we just we're just a bunch of old
guys that I love being around each other
where's Bobby today does he come out has
he been out has he been involved with
the process absolutely yeah he's been
out who's this here a couple of days ago
he's all you know it's all six members
down all six characters are being taken
on in this movie